i go out of my dock at night up north
where i am now
and it's dark and this the expanse of
the heavens is laid out above me
and i look up
well i'm not thinking religious thoughts
i'm confronting infinite
the infinite itself and that moves you
inside and i would say it even moves you
to imitation you know because you know
what it means to have your head in the
stars
right i mean it means to be oriented up
in the highest possible manner and so
we're so compelled to imitate again at
an instinctual level that we can even
imitate the infinite that we see spread
above us in the night sky and that's a
religious calling
and all this talk about whether you
believe in god and it's all
propositionalized it's like
well it misses the point it's that's why
i don't ever answer when people say do
you believe in god i say what do you
mean by believe
and they think well you know what i mean
it's like no you don't know what you
mean you have a bunch of assumptions
that you don't even recognize that
you're peppering the question with to
force me into a box to deliver the kind
of answer that your question demands
given the way you phrased it
it's like
no
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an author a lecturer a psychologist and
the world's preeminent lobster expert
jordan peterson my old friend welcome
back to the reuben report
hi dave so good to see you and to be
doing this again
all right here we go again we've we've
done this a couple times i thought we'd
do it a little differently this time
instead of just me tossing you up for
some questions if we did a little kind
of push and pull and churn through
some of these ideas but i guess where we
start first is you're in toronto i'm in
los angeles we we live in places that
are
seemingly really out of touch with a lot
of the things we talk about people ask
me about that a lot
how's life in toronto right now
well
in relationship to the covid
restrictions
i talked to a senior advisor to one of
the provincial governments a couple of
weeks ago he told me flat out that the
covet policy here is driven by nothing
but opinion polls related to the
popularity of the government no science
no end game in sight no real plan
and so what that means is that the the
part of the population that's most
afraid of covid i know it's what 50 of
democrats believe that you have a 50
shot at getting hospitalized if you
catch covet and 25 percent of
republicans
and so i suspect it's similar in canada
and so policy has being driven by people
who are more afraid than they should be
and
it's well it was a very disheartening
conversation because i trust this guy
and he he knows what he's talking about
and so you know
i'm i wouldn't say i'm cynical about
governments exactly because
cynicism is
it's a cheap
shortcut to approximating wisdom let's
say and you have to be judicious in your
criticisms but i still found that
extremely disheartening because i
thought at least policies that i don't
agree with the restrictive policies
were at least driven by something
remotely resembling a scientifically
informed plan and he was irate at what
had been happening enough to consider
resigning
so it's pretty appalling so what does
that tell you just at a psychological
level about fear in general if this
isn't driven by science and people hear
things on the media and then suddenly
they say okay yes please lock me in my
house please keep me in a mask forever
please keep me not going to holidays
with my family just psychologically
has that unearthed anything that maybe
you thought wasn't as intense i think i
think the thing that surprised me the
most probably was how rapidly we
stampeded to imitate a totalitarian
state in the immediate aftermath of the
release of covid now you know if you
think it through a little bit
no one really knew how serious the virus
was going to be and so it was an unknown
threat
and so you can imagine a herd of animals
or a school of fish for for that matter
because this kind of phenomena is
universal throughout the animal kingdom
the cost of overreacting to a threat is
generally minimal compared to under
reacting to a real threat right
overreacting to a hypothetical threat is
cheap compared to under reacting to an
actual threat because if you under react
you can die whereas if you overreact you
generally just get tired for a minute so
a hurdle stampede because the most
neurotic member of the herd jumps first
and then they'll instantly follow them
and that's kind of what we did in the
early stages of the pandemic the chinese
acted first now unfortunately they are a
totalitarian state and we all followed
and that's excusable in some sense
because we didn't know what sort of
threat we were facing
but then the
the breakdown it's really appalling in
canada the breakdown of our our rights
let's say for mobility
uh for freedom of speech etc it's
particularly grating to me in the
canadian context because way back in the
80s
prime minister pierre trudeau our
current prime minister's father who was
quite an intellectual
he was very enamored of french civil law
and he grafted a bill of rights on top
of the canadian federal common law
structure essentially and i i didn't
like that at all i thought that was a
bastardization of
a great english common law tradition i'm
not a fan of bills of rights because
they're predicated on the idea that you
have a finite set of rights and that the
social contract awards them to you or
the government and i think that's
backwards it's like you have all the
rights there are
except those that are expressly
forbidden by detailed legislation that
mostly was generated from the bottom up
that's the english common law tradition
anyways everybody celebrated the bill of
rights are you protected oh my god we
all our rights are protected now forever
you know it was
pierre trudeau's major accomplishment
hypothetically now we have his son and
it's like
yeah
what's it good for
my my father isn't vaccinated he decided
not to partly because they were telling
him he had to
and he has his other reasons
i have family members who aren't
vaccinated for health reasons who also
had covid twice and didn't really feel
they needed to be vaccinated again
in any case
it's extraordinarily annoying to see
this happening and to then find out that
there's nothing behind it except
like the most instrumental
and cowardly
random polling
is extremely disheartening and also
maddening and also angering all of those
things at once
and do you think it's possible that the
polling is out of whack too i mean
you've got you've been doing polling
forever right i mean this is this is one
of course it's out of whack jesus christ
you know i mean
how do you get accurate polling data
well okay over what time frame you're
gonna poll every day how about every
hour how about every minute
every week every two weeks
who answers the phone calls when you do
the polls how did you construct the
questions are you eliciting a particular
kind of answer because you paid
insufficient attention to the way the
question was posed etc etc so it's it's
not
guidance from the polls it's it's a
quasi-informed random walk which is a
lot easier than thinking it through but
to to see that happening
in spite of the much vaunted protection
for our rights like you know canadians
who are unvaccinated now cannot leave
the country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm look i got vaccinated and people
took me to task for that and i thought
all right i'll get the damn vaccine
here's the deal guys i'll get the
vaccine you [ __ ] leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for kovid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
stringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
and i don't think the evidence that
unvaccinated or that vaccinated people
are less contagious let's say i don't
think it's very compelling yeah
so
why are the vaccinated all of a sudden
the unvaccinated all of a sudden a
danger and i certainly don't understand
the push to get children vaccinated i
think that's i think that's
i think that's absolutely reprehensible
and i also can't figure out
norman deutsch wrote a piece in tablet
called needlepoints and one of the
things he pointed out was that if you
take the top 25 least trusted
institutions
um
in that group the most distrusted
institutions include
big pharma
and for good reason and he details out
the lawsuits that big pharma has had to
pay because of mis behavior on on their
part broadly speaking multiple companies
over the last 20 years and they're the
biggest lawsuits in american history
which is really saying something because
your court system is set up so that
big lawsuits are really possible right
and so i see the leftists all of a
sudden it's like big pharma yeah trust
them it's like what
what really
you guys
this is
i don't understand that at all like and
psychologically so what's going on here
it's like well i think the underlying
phenomena is something like phenomenon
is something like well as long as it's
for health and safety it's always good
and you know not to get conspiratorial
here but the same damn thing is going to
happen with the climate change push
absolutely they're already it's already
being reconfigured as well it's the
biggest public health issue of our time
it's like no i don't think so i think
overreaching bureaucrats are the biggest
health uh
what would you say the biggest challenge
to our health of our time
so and i think that's especially true of
the cop 26 bunch you know the chinese
just announced today i believe it was
today they're building 150 new nuclear
reactors
like not one
150
and we can't get our act together in the
states and canada for that matter to
build like one and in california they're
going to shut what 10 percent of the
power there down it's like no nuclear
well what are we going to replace it
with wind yeah well only if we put
windmills in front of the politicians
pushing for wind
you know can you imagine how much wind
it would take to blow your car down the
road
so it's so
it's
and so if those people at the climate
change summit were serious what they
would be and and we could be very very
specific about this here's what you do
if you're
a leftist who's
concerned about the environment and the
poor simultaneously
okay
you make power energy as cheap as
possible for everyone because there's no
difference between energy and wealth and
because rich people can't hoard energy
it's not a pareto problem right because
all the energy doesn't end up in the
hands of a few
so you try to build nuclear reactors
perhaps there's a bit of a problem
getting rid of the waste and there's a
lot of bureaucratic wrangling around
that it's not a solved problem entirely
but we don't have a better option than
nuclear in the long run
and so you make power as cheap as
possible so if you want to save the
climate you want to make power
everywhere in the world as cheap as
possible as fast as possible to make
people as rich as possible because the
richer they get the more they care about
the environment and that pattern is
clear in china and india which have
greened substantially in the last 20
years those two countries have greened
an area the size of the amazon in the
last 20 years and that's in addition by
the way just so everyone knows here's a
cool little fact you know that as carbon
dioxide levels rise
plants can grow in drier environments
drier environments semi-arid like
deserts like like
the sandbanks on oceans and lakes
stabilizing that as well and so because
the carbon dioxide levels have risen the
plants can close their pores the
breathing pores and so they don't
evaporate water as much and so an area
the size of alaska has greened in the
last couple of decades in addition to
what china and india have planted
and so
you know so what i worked for the the un
secretary general's committee on
sustainable development and to some
degree cop 26 is an attempt to bring the
corporate world in line with those
developmental goals and there was a
bunch of problems with the project
because there were 200 goals and that's
too many you have to prioritize them and
no one was willing to accept bjorn
lomberg and that's a different
conversation but what i learned because
i read about 200 books at that time on
the environment and sustainable
development and what i learned was
things are way better than anybody
thinks we have a glorious future in
front of us if we want to the best way
to save the planet is to make poor
people rich as fast as we possibly can
so that means we can have our cake and
eat it too and isn't that absolutely
lovely
and the biggest environmental issue
that's facing us isn't global warming
it's over fishing in the oceans as far
as i'm concerned because that's that we
could actually stop it's actually
extremely damaging and we know how to
stop it and trudeau to his credit by the
way has
uh produced a series of marine protected
areas along canada's coastline that
weren't there before now i don't know
how protected they are and how thorough
that legislation is but that's something
that that he's done that that actually
counts as a credible accomplishment in
my estimation
so but
go ahead dave well so first off i you
know i've interviewed bjorn a couple
times but we his last book basically
illustrates i mean it's it's mostly
illustrations that lay out almost
everything you're saying here so i just
want people to know you're not making it
up we'll link to that interview so they
don't know so they can see it but yeah
go ahead okay so well look so so there's
these 200 development goals and
sustainable it's like okay well what is
sustainable mean and over what time
frame that's actually incredibly
complicated right because
time frame is a real problem do we mean
sustainable over 5000 years well why
should we care because god only knows
what the world's going to be like in 5
000 years just look at what computer
technology is doing we can't plan out
that far so that's probably too long
hundred years
well we're all dead then
and you might think well we should care
it's like yeah perhaps but how should we
care because we can't predict that far
out so the time frame is really crucial
and it's and then the fact that there
are 200 goals that's that's like zero
goals
like if you were trying to do 200 things
first of all at any moment you wouldn't
be able to do anything because at any
moment you can only do one thing and so
you have to prioritize and i asked
repeatedly when i was working on this
committee
why
aren't these goals prioritized and the
answer was well they all have separate
constituencies who are fighting for that
particular value and they get annoyed if
there's any like sequential approach
it's like okay well that just means we
do nothing because 200 goals is just
chaos
and then i found lomberg and
and so what lombard does is he he hires
teams of economists to assess the goals
in a given country or globally for that
matter
by cost benefit and you can you can
argue about that because there's
assumptions that you have to use that
are built into your analysis right
there's always eight prior axioms and
prejudices and biases and so forth and
constraints but he does it with 10
different teams of economists so that's
kind of good and then he averages across
the whole set of the economists and then
you might say well it's an economic
analysis and that doesn't take anything
into everything into account it's like a
everything can't be taken into account
and b
do you have a better idea
and if not then well what good is your
criticism
like i haven't seen a better idea than
lomberg's idea
but from anyone
so
is is part of the problem that people
because our institutions have in so many
ways failed us and i know you've
obviously talked about it and wrote
about it in your last book that we
shouldn't just needlessly want to burn
down these institutions but they've
they've sort of failed us to the point
that when they do these conferences like
these climate conferences i was
listening to obama's speech yesterday
and he's going on and on about how we're
going to have to sacrifice and all that
meanwhile he just yeah who's going to
have to sacrifice who's going to have to
sacrifice his million dollar house he
just bought a 15 million dollar house on
the water in martha's vineyard i was
just down in miami trust me there's of
40 million dollar mansions well there
you go dave that's a sacrifice because
he didn't buy a 40 million dollar
mansion
right so we should be thankful for him
as he flew but let's talk about
sacrifice yeah yeah okay so yeah let's
let the old people freeze in the dark
that's what's going to happen in europe
if we get a cold winter
so who's going to sacrifice here well i
can tell you the answer to that let's
play leftist here for a minute okay
so
there are hierarchies and i think
they're competence hierarchies but
they're corrupted by power to some
degree
and how much is worthy of investigation
and we should always clean them up i
mean you just did that in some sense
when you said our institutions are
corrupt right and we have to be very
judicious which institutions where are
they corrupt how are they corrupt at a
level of detail and in
analyzed in a manner that allows us to
fix them instead of replace them
wholesale right so okay in any case
in a hierarchy when there's stress
illness and death climb from the bottom
up
that's partly why you want to be nearer
the top in a hierarchy because it's
actually
psychophysiologically easier
well obviously because otherwise why
would you strive for it i mean there are
other reasons you know maybe you want to
do do good for other people maybe you're
motivated by power maybe you're a
psychopath maybe you're acting
instrumentally there's lots of other
reasons but one of the consequences of
success is that
you don't die
so who dies first well as soon as you
stress the system let's say we double
energy prices
well who's gonna what's the sacrifice
well old poor people
because they're more susceptible to say
death when the air conditioning when
they can't afford air conditioning when
they can afford heat
and so yeah but there's too many people
on the planet anyway so you know what
the hell we call a few
few whatever you know they're just poor
people and this is the thing that bugs
me so much it's like okay leftists
which side are you on here
it's like are you gonna are you gonna
sacrifice the poor
to your hypothetical future utopia yeah
but they're all going to die anyways
because the planet's going to burn no
it's not the ipcc never said that
that so bjorn bjorn has modeled out you
know a reasonable amount of climate
change in meaning temperature increase
over the next 100 years he's taken
what's promoted as the scientific
consensus there is no consensus in
science that's not how science works
it's not a consensus enterprise but
nonetheless he's playing along with it
okay we'll take your figures
it's going to produce somewhat of a
decrement in gb in in global economic
growth but growth is about four percent
a year and so even if that declines a
chunk because of global warming it
everyone's still going to be like five
times as rich as they are now in a
hundred years if we don't screw things
up and so maybe they'll be four times as
rich
well that's a cost and fair enough you
know and if we can ameliorate it we
shouldn't probably we should probably
try not to change natural environments
any faster than we have to right because
of unexpected consequences it's a
reasonable argument but like here's
another thing this this
net zero
okay as soon as you hear someone say
anything like that zero you know they're
not thinking
it's like zero tolerances
to zero we shouldn't be trying to get
coaches yeah right exactly exactly well
and we don't have zero tolerance for
drugs
zero is the wrong number
zero pollution
well no
you know cows there's there's manure
from cows
people go to the bathroom
there's not zero pollution
so net zero it's just it's an empty
talking point to put up a flag that
you're on the right side it's not
differentiated careful thoughtful
thorough detail-oriented thinking at the
level that will actually produce
solutions and there's no discussion
about like what are we aiming at here
well how about
copious energy for everyone
as clean as possible but but in that
order copious energy for everyone lowest
possible price resilient stable systems
and to the credit to their credit the
democrats and their infrastructure bill
are building resilience goals in in
relationship to the power grid and
that's necessary because we should be
stress testing those systems constantly
but if you're on the left and you care
about poor people the only thing you
should really care about is cheap energy
and why is that let's be very precise
about this okay what makes people
prosperous and secure work
what is work it is the expenditure of
energy
what is energy work what is work
wealth
you want to deal with absolute poverty
or even relative poverty for that matter
energy is everything and here's you know
here's another fact
so
you know you americans have actually
knocked your carbon dioxide output down
14 in the last couple of decades
you know why
fracking
because it's it made natural gas cheap
and replace dirtier forms of energy plus
it made you way less reliant on
opec and the russians
and how is that not good for planetary
stability you talk about
the environment how about not a third
world war
because that's not so good for the
environment
and so fracking knocked carbon dioxide
out put the us down 14
who would have predicted that
and in shellenberger's book apocalypse
never he
he he uh interviewed an mit scientist he
said you really want to knock carbon
dioxide output down
make
india and china but india he was
speaking of more particularly switch to
coal as fast as possible you think coal
why oh it's better than wood
and we know the pattern would that's not
so good
you'd cut down trees you cut down
forests it's really polluting especially
indoors and that kills a lot of people
stunts a lot of children's growth you
know growth in the in the broad sense
because indoor pollution is much more
deadly than outdoor pollution generally
speaking
so and wood well you have to cut down
forests it's inefficient it puts
particulates in the atmosphere as well
so you switch to coal coal is better
it's not wood to begin with and then
it's not where near as polluting and
coal technologies have got quite clean
now you still have to mine the coal and
there's an environmental cost for that
well then you switch from coal to
natural gas natural gas is pretty damn
good there's lots of it it's plentiful
it's clean
and then maybe you know if we can get
our act together and have some sense we
could switch from natural gas to
fission
well and then we could have energy for
everyone at the lowest possible cost and
then what happens while people get rich
and then what happens they care about
the environment so how is that not the
right solution to let's not call it
climate change because that that's
annoying
it's like let's not produce any more
waste than we have to while we try to
live
fair enough you know that's a reasonable
goal but all i see coming out of the
these cop 26 conferences and that thing
sort of thing is here's a bunch of
people doing it wrong and let's stop
them it's like yeah yeah right guys why
don't you try to do something instead so
okay that's exactly where i wanted to go
with this are we just at the point where
the machinery the institutions the media
tech the whole machinery of how we
communicate to each other has broken
down to the point that if everything you
said right there you you stepped into an
office and you were sitting down with
all of those people or even just aoc and
the the people here that want the green
new deal and you laid all that out that
they would
basically just say yeah well you know
okay good for him he's got some studies
no
i don't believe that i don't believe
that i think we have to be judicious in
our institutional criticisms well
there's a bunch of reasons for that
first of all
that infrastructure bill that was just
passed
that's nowhere near as stupid as it
could have been
and if you look at the white house
messaging well that's something isn't it
yeah it's something it's something it's
something man and if you look at the
white house messaging it's about two
percent diversity inclusivity and equity
and that's not too bad because zero is
asking for too much as we already
discussed and you know i've talked to
lots of democrats and lots of
republicans and there are people of good
will who are competent on both sides and
they're trying
you know people don't understand here so
you're a congressman federally
you know
all right so i went to washington and i
talked to a whole bunch of them trying
to find out i read this book a long time
ago called systematics it's a great book
by john gall it's a great book system
antics
one of its dictums is the system does
not do what its name says it does
and so then the question is what does it
do well then you have to look
so like i worked at social services for
the alberta government when i was a kid
and
social services what do they do
well i was tasked weirdly enough when i
was about 19 to find out to update a
big consulting company's analysis of
spending of the social services
department they had paid them some
hundreds of thousands of dollars and i
was just working as a summer intern and
they said update this and i thought huh
okay and so i phoned around trying to
get the figures and no one knew what
they were the system had no idea where
the money it was spending went so i was
trying to get stats like uh how much of
the welfare money spent actually goes to
recipients
couldn't find the data
then i realized okay
social services what does it do
it probably spends 95 percent of its
money on bureaucrats who are
implementing social service programs and
then i thought well should i be cynical
about that
it's like
well no
it's actually hard to distribute money
and if five percent of it goes to its
target that might not be too bad it's
not great by the way but but it's it's
better than running at a deficit or zero
and so and many charities are like that
if they get 10 to the recipients they're
doing pretty well and you can be cynical
about that in any case when i went so in
any case when i went to washington i
thought okay these are congress people
what do they do
well hypothetically they analyze policy
they set out strategy they talk to their
constituents no they spend 25 hours a
week fundraising
25 hours a week both both sides both
sides they can't do it in their
congressional offices because that's
illegal so they have other offices in
these industrial warehouses you know
with drop ceilings and they basically
are telemarketers 25 hours a week well
how the hell can those people get
anything done
then i had lunches where there was some
democrats and some republicans generally
more junior members just trying to get
to know each other and i had them go
around the table and say why they went
into public service and you couldn't
have asked for more patriotic heartfelt
declarations of virtuous intent and you
couldn't tell the democrats from the
republicans not on the basis of that
and so then they and then you say well
why do they fundraise 25 hours a week
well they have to be elected every two
years
and then the party apparatus because
they don't really know how to spend
money effectively
communicating with people to get them to
vote for them they think money will do
it
they won't support them unless they
raise a certain amount of money
well how the hell can those people do
their job
and so you sit down and you talk to them
and and
the vast majority of them are
they're even self-sacrificing it's like
it's not a job i would want there isn't
a lot of security in it if you're
competent you could go do something else
and be paid more and be harassed a hell
of a lot less
they're trying and when you lay out the
sorts of arguments that i've been laying
out i rarely
talk to anyone who's competent of
goodwill and i don't care whether on the
democrat or republican side
that doesn't see the logic in this
and so
what we've got to be aware of on the on
the conservative and then on the leftist
and
especially you guys in the states is do
not throw the baby out with the
bathwater like i went to new york city
here four days ago
that's a great city
you have a great country it's a work of
art
don't screw it up with with facile
criticisms
like there are things wrong because
there always are but you got the devil's
in the details man you got to do a
detailed analysis it's like you know the
leftists say well the whole judicial
system is corrupt what's the evidence
well the disproportionate incarceration
rate it's like you know that's a fairly
damning indictment
okay
where exactly
is it going wrong
exactly precisely procedurally
so that we could fix it well the whole
thing has to be burned to the ground
it's like
yeah well
no and you aren't thinking
so you're not helpful
and then you take a problem like that
apart the differential incarceration
rate man that's a rat's nest it's
complicated man you know it goes it's
tangled up with slavery it's tangled up
with jim crow it's tangled up with
differential exposure to literacy in
childhood it's tangled up with single
parent families
violent communities
uh
the drug war drug policy
just to name a few then then you know we
could say whatever
whatever
implicit racism still exists because
that's not zero
it's very very complicated and people
don't want to detail a detailed
on-the-ground analysis of such problems
what they want to do is label it with a
low resolution representation so like a
one pixel representation
and then they want to contrast that with
the wrong one pixel representation then
they want to feel the moral virtue that
they should have would have felt if they
had actually solved the problem so so
how do we fix the resolution and when i
ask you this i include myself in this
you know i'm talking about news every
day on the show i try to do it in the
most honest way possible obviously i
have my biases i'm not pretending that i
have no opinions um but you know often
often when you get bludgeoned over the
head with sort of the the low resolution
stuff enough your resolution starts
getting screwed up so how do we
arbitrage those two positions it's not
just bias right it's not just bias it's
also heuristics and there's a difference
like a heuristic is a functional
simplification
and we use heuristics all the time like
the image you see of me is a heuristic
because you are not seeing me well first
of all i'm not there second even if you
were seeing me if we were in person
you'd still be seeing a heuristic
because you don't see my subatomic
structure
you don't see my cellular structure you
don't see the context that i'm embedded
in you see it you see an iconic image
that stands for the reality that's too
complex to perceive and so
it's not easy to tell when you're using
an appropriate heuristic and the basic
rule of thumb is you use the simplest
thumbnail you can use that will get the
job done
now the question is then the question is
well what is the job
and you have to ask yourself well how
much unearned moral superiority are you
actually striving for
and the answer generally is a lot
and and that's that's how a heuristic
turns into a bias
and it's it's so it's partly ignorance
some of it's malevolence and willful
blindness but it's partly ignorance it's
like you just don't know
right you don't even know what you don't
know
and so
and then you think well isn't it
interesting that you have people who
will pontificate about fixing the
electrical system the power system
who
couldn't wire up a plug-in in their
house and you think well does that
matter it's like well yes in some sense
it does matter because unless there's a
a chain of causality built from the
highest level abstractions right down to
the power outlet itself the plan
in some sense is deeply flawed
and then and then we have another
problem david so look when i worked on
this un committee i was on the canadian
subsection of the committee there was
only one canadian subsection
and
i was pulled in by the man who ran that
and i worked on it for about two years
and i i was serious about it and i
rewrote fair chunks of that
document this the sustainable goals
guide partly because it was stuck in
like 1985 with this old cold war
mentality it was terribly written so i
just rewrote a bunch of it and what
happened was a lot of those rewrites
stuck and that was shocking it's like
what the hell
how did that happen
and the answer was
well i did the work
and in order for someone to change it
they would have had to
rewrite it
and then you think well why didn't they
and the answer is well they didn't
really have time
so these things work in a weird way so
so this this uh
guide to sustainable developments
becomes sort of a centerpiece of
i wouldn't say cop 26 exactly but
similar large-scale
endeavors to sort of steer where the
planet's going okay so how was that put
together well the u.n secretary general
nominated a bunch of ex-presidents and
ex-prime ministers like high-end people
right
but the thing about those people is
they're busy
like their days are scheduled it doesn't
matter if they're former presidents or
prime ministers their days are scheduled
to the minute for like 16 hours
well they don't have time to sit and
analyze the sustainable goals
development
sustainable development goals
so then it falls down the hierarchy of
bureaucracy until it lands on the desk
if someone who actually either wants to
or has time to do it
and god only knows how many tears down
it has to fall before that person takes
it on and then are they trained to do
this
well no
the only person i know that's trained to
do it would be lomberg
you know and he doesn't have the
expertise necessary to really do it but
he's still the one i would say knows
better than anyone
broadly speaking that i've met
and it's not like we have training
schools to prepare people to prepare
documents on sustainable development
over the next hundred years for the
planet it requires so much expertise
and so these things are cobbled together
you know
and it's not even a conspiracy you know
you don't have to posit a conspiracy
and ideas can take on a conspiratorial
form all by themselves themselves you
know this is no conspiracy
it's so badly done that it's quite
frightening so then then where would you
piece the the algorithmic part of this
the tech part that then you have a bunch
of people that are not quite qualified
to be
well they can be discussing it but
perhaps analyzing it or giving the
policy prescriptions that are constantly
fighting about these things all day and
then keeping a whole bunch of other
people in a perpetual state of confusion
or fear i mean that's the piece of this
that emerged just in the last 20 years
that seems to hide the rest of it like
it sits higher in that hierarchy okay i
need more specificity so what do you
mean exactly are you talking about the
political battles around this sort of
thing or i'm talking about the political
battles i'm talking about the cultural
battles all of it the stuff that that
generates the clicks that keeps us all
watching things that keeps us all
looking at our phones well often is done
by a class of people that are not the
ones that you're saying should be sort
of analyzing this stuff properly
well okay let's look at what the tech
companies are doing
well
let's let's play angels advocate for a
minute
okay they are really trying to deliver
you something you will attend to
they really are trying to do that and
they are building unbelievably powerful
ai machines to analyze even your bloody
eye movements to see what you're looking
at you think oh my god that's scary it's
like
yes and no
they are also trying to figure out what
you want
and need and deliver it to you as fast
as possible
amazon click
bang at your doorstep
yeah okay well they know a lot about you
but it turns out you actually have to
know a lot about someone in order to be
able to do that so can we trust them
can we trust us
well
not if we're lying
like that's the that's the critical
issue here it's not even ideology
exactly although we could get into that
it's lying
that corrupts all of this that turns a
heuristic into a bias that turns
information into misinformation and so
these companies that are trying to serve
us to the degree that there's deceit and
let's say the naked desire for power and
control as kind of a psychopathic edge
to the degree that that's operative all
these systems get contaminated and we
definitely have to be on the lookout for
that but we can't demonize the
corporations the tech corporations in
the same way i mean look what we're
doing
i'm like 3 000 miles away from you
and you and i are having a conversation
that a million people are going to watch
that we can publish in five minutes and
it'll be distributed like a book used to
be instantly
it's like my god what a miracle like
here's another miracle this is something
man
so i have these teams of translators
working on my youtube content
and that's been put together by a very
diligent team who have familiarized
themselves in 13 languages with the
idiom of the languages it's not google
translate it's proved very hard to take
english youtube content let's say video
content and translate it to other
languages because it hasn't been
thought through carefully enough and
this has particularly been the case for
my russian translation team
and so
three weeks ago i talked to my head
russian translator who i hadn't met
before very bright guy
and we had a real-time conversation
because zoom has now enabled a feature
so if you have a simultaneous translator
it'll suppress the russian and only let
you hear the english
and so now with a real-time translator i
can talk to anyone in the world
and then i can record that i mean this
is a technological marvel that's
unparalleled it's unbelievable it's just
like one thing that zoom added as a
feature you know in the last couple of
months
this demonizat this simple
oversimplification and demonization this
has to stop
you know here's something horrible i
talked to andy noe yesterday
okay and i said look i talked to a bunch
of democrats influential democrats about
antifa and they said antifa is illusory
and i thought okay you believe that but
you believe there's a conspiratorial
force that's very powerful on the right
that's real okay so they believe that
but they don't believe antifa is real
so we give the devil a stew well what do
you mean real exactly
okay so i asked andy no who's been like
half he's been beat mostly to death
twice and been severely hurt twice while
reporting on this he's a brave guy
i said well you know these lefties the
moderates these are reasonable people
i'm talking to they're certainly people
who as who are as morally good as me
let's say so
what what do they mean
is it illusory
well i said well
how many actually organized antifa
groups are they like organized so there
is identifiable group with identifiable
people they're kind of working full time
on this they have a leader they have a
website you can point to them he figured
maybe 20.
i said well like how many people do you
think in each of those groups are
committed to the antifa
ethos
whatever that is fascist
anarchist
left-wing
paramilitary like who the hell are these
people are they left or right or does
that matter or maybe they're a weird
mixture of both and it's to their
advantage
to have the left think they're right and
the right think they're left because
really what they're after is chaos
and that could easily be the case in
fact i'm sure it is the case he figured
oh maybe in each of those groups there's
20 to 30 people 40 maybe
so there's like 800 of them
okay so that means they don't exist in
some sense so if you took a city the
size of halifax
which isn't a big city but it's a city
there'd be one guy like that in the
whole city
so does it exist well
not really it's it's not an
organization he talked about rose city
antifa as the sort of epicenter of this
trouble but here's what we're really
facing it isn't left-wing radicals who
are trying to take over cities that's a
way of looking at it it's
agents of chaos who's in who in whose
interest it is to sow discord as
thoroughly as possible and then the
question is well how do in this age of
interconnectedness
how do we protect ourselves we
republicans and democrats alike
the 95 percent of people who make up the
reasonable middle how do we protect
ourselves against 800 malevolent
psychopaths
and that's the endless question of the
human race
so i want to spin something off sideways
from that just momentarily
men are less agreeable than women
it's a it's a it's a reliable
personality difference it's only about
60 40. so if you picked a man and a
woman out of a crowd and you tried to
figure out who was least agreeable if
you bet on the man you'd be right 60 of
the time that's not that much but it's
not nothing it means all the really
disagreeable people are men
right out of the extremes okay so
and women actually like disagreeable men
more than agreeable men
so there's a preference which is why
we're like that because women are
powerful agents of sexual selection and
they decide that that's how disagreeable
men should be
why
okay so here's the trade-off right
the more disagreeable you are
the less empathic and compassionate and
polite you are so the less in some sense
the less generous the less concerned
with others the more concerned with
yourself and your victories
okay so why would women pick men who are
more disagreeable than them
well that's the beauty and the beast
problem in some part
right now you want a disagreeable man
but you want him to be tameable
so it means you don't want him to be so
disagreeable he can't be generous and
caring and share
but you don't want him to be so
agreeable that a psychopath can take him
out
and and i mean this is a technical issue
because
so you might say
so
noah also talked about what happened in
one of these cities that set up one of
those sort of autonomous zones the mayor
i think it was i can't remember the city
probably seattle was chop
i think yeah seattle it was seattle
you're exactly right the mayor said
something like well maybe it'll be sort
of like a summer of love it's like yeah
maybe but we remember how the summer of
love ended by the way yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh hell's angels biker gangs at
their rolling stones concert
so so anyways
summer love okay so everybody's
agreeable and they're getting along and
they're handing out food which isn't
free by the way but is free in the
states because we're so efficient
essentially
it's all summer love stuff
yeah but what about the psychopaths
well when did they come out how about at
night
so like that this is naive beyond belief
and there are computer models of this so
if you set up communities of
hyper-agreeable people all they do is
share and you know they're daisies
growing out of their
orifices
what happens
you throw one shark in the water and
everyone gets eaten okay so women have
this tough problem because they have to
protect their infants and they can't
really do it because they're smaller and
they're you know they're concerned with
their infants they're occupied they need
men to guard them well that means they
mean men who can be guards so that they
have to pay a price in agreeableness the
women do
and you know sometimes i've seen couples
where the man is just so masculine
and the woman so feminine that they
can't even communicate they're like from
different planets mars and venus they
just can't bridge the gap and so this is
a really tough evolutionary problem it's
like you have to have generosity you
have to have toughness
because you got to keep down the
cheaters and the miscreants they have to
be held under control and you're naive
to think that that's not the case
psychopaths
by the way
psychopaths vary in the general
population between about one and five
percent and seem to stabilize it about
three percent
and so that's also a big critique of the
leftist notion that hierarchies are
nothing but power because if that was
true psychopaths would be much more
prevalent than they are and way more
successful and what happens is once the
psychopaths get past a certain
percentage of the population people wake
up to them and the tough guys stop them
and like is that really surprising to
anyone it's like the tough policemen
stop them the tough military guys stop
them there's no such thing as tough guys
and isn't it the case that they're
actually tougher than tough women
and so what are we children here or are
we gonna look at this straightforwardly
and clearly yeah and that that is what
it so much of this seems to boil down to
to me that we just seem to be afraid to
confront these what i don't think are
actually that it's not that they're not
complex issues but they're things that
we used to talk about honestly i mean
you know how frustrated i've been with
you know with a lot of the sort of
liberal intelligentsia that in many ways
i think ushered so much of this in that
yeah now now saying oh now we've got a
problem but it's like guys yeah well i'm
i'm still appalled at the faculty
and you know what i saw happening when i
was a faculty member i retired this year
um in some sense i'm teaching like
hundreds of thousands of people now
instead of hundreds and so that seems
like a better idea
but what i saw the faculty do in my
career not at harvard by the way
was continually seed territory to the
administration one cowardly decision at
a time one cowardly micro decision at a
time and i really think that's the sin
of the left the moderate left
it's
cowardly retreats on micro issues
the sin on the right is probably the
right has bigger sins and they're more
obvious and they're sort of clumped
together you know so but the left it's
like this continual retreat so first of
all the faculty retreated and the
administration took over which was a
really bad idea i used to fight with my
faculty members at the university of
toronto the administration would do
something arbitrary like say well how
about your third year seminars fourth
year seminars have like 30 people in
them instead of 15.
oh it's like well then they're not a
seminar
so then i say well how about we just say
no
hire more faculty just no we will not do
that well they would they would have
capitulated instantly the administration
if we would have said no
for sure
but they never said no
and i said well why won't you say no
well they won't give us what we want
then well they don't give you what you
want anyways i saw an endless number of
five-year plans come and go where
nothing that was promised was ever
delivered i'm not being cynical about
this i mean the university of toronto
ran pretty reasonably for our overgrown
and heavily bureaucratized institution
so it was all these retreats well then
these insane ideas came in
you know and here's the fundamental idea
and it really deals with the mystery i'm
writing this new book about it called we
who wrestle with god
we don't know how we manage the act of
perception
we actually don't know it's really
complicated that's why we don't have
general purpose robots
is because perceiving the world turns
out to be way more complicated than
anybody ever imagined because we kind of
think well there's objects out there and
you just see them
it's like if you take a picture of a
landscape and you put it in photoshop
and then you blow it up you can't tell
where the lines are between the objects
well the real world is kind of like that
it's like
and even defining simple things is like
what's a table
well it's a flat surface with four legs
well okay is a dollhouse table a table
how about if you put a plate full of
food on a stump and sit down to it is
that a table
what if this stump is actually kind of
slanted
what if it has a soft surface like maybe
you put a plate on a beanbag
is that now a table
well if a table might not be a flat
surface with four legs or one leg or
three legs or triangular surface it
might be a place you put a plate full of
food on to sit down and eat at which is
a functional definition
and it turns out that most of the things
we see are actually functional icons
rather than objects and then you can't
get a machine to see that because
they're not embodied
in any case
the mystery of perception how do we
categorize it's a great mystery and
they'll answer the left left to in the
face of this immense mystery which is
how can finite creatures comprehend the
infinite well enough to function
that's the mystery their answer was all
our categories are based on the
expression of will to power
and you know that's actually partly true
because part of our motivation is to
move up hierarchies but that can be
based on competence and all of our
institutions are corrupted by power and
deceit so if they would have said
part of our categorization is will to
power no problem it would have left the
mystery open
and this is a huge mystery it's a
religious mystery in the final analysis
i believe
and you know if you if you have faith
you believe that it's something like
the spirit of goodness itself that does
categorization that that lays out our
basic perceptions and that would depend
on your motivation so we could say like
if you were oriented
in the highest manner you could be
oriented
then the contents of your categories
would be
subservient to the good
and i think you have to be immensely
cynical to think that will to power is a
more powerful force than that
and that sort of cynicism that devours
the world
and so we don't want to do that that's
and
i can see why the universities fell into
that because this was i think this was
the biggest mystery that emerged
philosophically in the last half of the
20th century it's like oh my see because
what happened on in the english
departments it was
well we don't know how we perceive even
like a simple landscape
okay well how about a text
oh well wait a minute how many ways can
you interpret a text oh
a near infinite number of ways this is
true technically a near infinite number
of ways
well okay which of those
interpretations should take priority
well
we don't know how we figure that out
and so well how do we know it's not just
the naked expression of power
well sometimes it is
and that that's the idea it's like this
is a problem now it's the wrong solution
because
it isn't the naked will to the
fundamental human motivation is not the
naked will to power here's the
fundamental human motivation
it's
i'll tell you a quick story if you don't
mind hopefully it'll be quick
i went to see dye meistersinger in new
york the opera
okay so it's it's very cool this opera
i'm going to write about it in in detail
in this book but here's the basic story
there's a town called nuremberg and
there's a bunch of guilds in the town
craftsmen
cobblers
like blacksmiths guys who work who make
things right so they're glued right to
the bottom they know how to wire the
electrical outlet
now they've all organized together and
elected a meister a master singer in
each guild so the head of the guild
isn't one of the craftsmen although he
is a craftsman he also has to be a
singer
okay now all these guild guys get
together the singers and they elect each
news singer
and so the story is set up so that
a new singer is going to be elected and
one of the
craftsmen singers says he'll stake his
entire fortune and his daughter
on this new contest he'll award his
daughter to the new master singer
although she has a choice she doesn't
have to do it by the way so this isn't
like patriarchal oppression it's a
father trying to offer his daughter the
best after judicious consideration
fully cognizant of the fact that he
loves her and allowing her her choice
encouraging her choice
a knight comes in who's wandered around
in the natural world and he's such a
great singer that they can't help but
recognize his talent but he breaks all
the rules
and the girl falls in love with him
okay so
the this guy who puts up his fortune
he says i'm willing to subordinate my
fortune
because people have criticized me for
only pursuing money i'm willing to
subordinate my fortune to the pursuit of
this highest art
and i'll put my daughter on the line too
it's like this is real
okay so the rest now
so the men all get together in these
guilds and they try to elect
the top figure and this guy's name is
all right the next thing that happens is
that the guilds degenerate into
competition because they're all fighting
for this girl
and that's what happens among men
it's like they do get together they do
elect someone who's highest among us
them and then the highest get together
and elect what is highest yet
that's what unites us
that's real
and we do fragment because of
competition so that can fall apart
anyways the opera is a masterful
exploration of all of that but it isn't
will to power that is at the basis of
categorization it's something like
respect for the divine word
and that's indistinguishable from truth
from truth
and that's is said against that's set
against the will to power and it's way
more try it out from your own life
do things for power
see what happens
that's hell
because even if you get what you want by
the time you get it you'll be a
psychopath no love
nothing
just corruption everywhere around you
truth that's a whole different thing
and we're so powerful now we better tell
the truth
we could have paradise laid out in front
of us if we were careful
or we could let everything burn
do you think you've made headway on this
when when you've talked i watched uh
just about a week ago with your your
chat with uh stephen pinker and jonathan
hey two guys who i hold in the highest
like intellectual regard i've had them
on the show i i like them both very much
they come from the more atheist
perspective on this you know we've
talked about this a million times
yeah so
right right okay so that that's it
that's that's not going to be that's
where your argument is that i'm going to
cambridge and oxford to talk about this
like in detail what i just laid out it's
like because i what i want to do is
especially when i go to the uk in these
conversations is i want to lay a tech i
lay out a technical argument for sacred
depth so imagine this
we have a intuition that there's depth
in literature
because we think well that's a shallow
story and that's a deep story and we
think well that was really compelling
and gripping it hit me at a profound
level right versus well that was just
light entertainment light right
we all have those intuitions
so what is this depth
and how far down does it go well it goes
down to the bottom of things
what's at the bottom well what's at the
bottom is by definition religious
and why would i say that well it's
because when things move you at that
level
that's how you experience it it's not
thought
it's way deeper so it's like
you go out i go out of my dock at night
up north where i am now
and it's dark and this the expanse of
the heavens is laid out above me
and i look up well i'm not thinking
religious thoughts
i'm confronting infinite
the infinite itself and that moves you
inside
and i would say it even moves you to
imitation you know because you know what
it means to have your head in the stars
right i mean it means to be oriented up
in the highest possible manner and so
we're so compelled to imitate again at
an instinctual level that we can even
imitate the infinite that we see spread
above us in the night sky and that's a
religious calling
and all this talk about whether you
believe in god and it's all
propositionalized it's like well it's it
misses the point
it's that's why i don't ever answer when
people say do you believe in god i say
what do you mean by believe
and they think well you know what i mean
it's like no you don't know what you
mean you have a bunch of assumptions
that you don't even recognize that
you're peppering the question with to
force me into a box to deliver the kind
of answer that your question demands
given the way you phrased it
it's like
no
you say you don't believe in god it's
like well god is ineffable
what do you mean you don't believe in
god well what do you believe in them
nothing
well no everything well no that doesn't
work because then you're chaotic well
what's your highest value diversity
equity inclusivity
well i don't need a highest value well
yes you do because otherwise nothing
orients you through the landscape of
choices
this isn't optional so to give the devil
is due then yeah when you've when you've
had the conversations with a lot of
these guys you just talked to sam harris
again also you know all of these guys
that went great by the way at the end um
you know people that are not necessarily
believers your your basic argument i'm
doing a little 101 here is that you're a
believer whether you believe it or not
that that you're being well harris yeah
okay let's take harris is a good example
harris does not believe in god
but he believes in the devil
so he's halfway there
and why do i say i think he believes
trump is the devil yeah yeah but that
okay but that's a mistake he also
believes religion is the devil and
that's also a mistake so what do i mean
when i say that he believes in the devil
well all i did the last time i talked to
sam was asking questions
that was a way and that's something i
highly recommend as a
as a strategy like just find out from
the person you're talking to what they
think
you know
and don't try to win
try to learn
well so sam is really motivated by the
same thing that motivated me like 30
years ago he looked at the panoply of
human atrocity
it terrified him right right to the core
it's like well anything but this and he
wants something like an objective
standard of values now he thinks it can
be found in science i think that's
technically wrong but it's it's an
argument worth having and we we don't
know how to sort out the relationship
between science and values but the thing
is is that sam certainly believes in
evil
okay well if you believe in evil you
also believe in good because good is the
opposite of evil whatever that is
and well what's god go what's god well
god is what's good
well okay what does that mean is he a
spirit like is he a spirit in the sky
what do you mean by spirit
so here here's a here's something to
think about this is what i think
when i look back at the good men
that i've been fortunate enough to know
in my life
there's a spirit that shines through
each of them
that makes them good that's how i can
tell that each of them is good well the
essence of that good that's no different
than god it might even be god
now you say well what does that mean
that spirit well it's whatever is common
among good men let's say
was that real well isn't what's common
among things more real than what's
different
and why a spirit well it animates them
like it's an it's an animating force
it's not a disembodied abstraction which
is the problem with like conceptions of
god like einstein's conception it's so
disembodied it has no connection to the
world
and that that causes the death of god
that abstraction
eliader
documented deaths of god in many
cultures across history it's not only
something that happened in the west that
nietzsche announced and it happens when
the idea of god gets so abstracted that
it no longer has any connection with the
world
well and those are the things i'm going
to talk about at cambridge and oxford
it's like and i'm going to talk to
richard dawkins
so that's so cool because i'd like to
ask him some questions and because
dawkins is smart and he's put forward
maybe the most coherent biologically
oriented
argument for clockwork determinism
something like that well jordan i mean i
have to tell you this is what i mean i
know you know this but when we were on
tour i think the the thing that you
changed beyond more than anything else i
talk about in my book there were two
things it was the importance of being a
parent because you would always say
most people to live a fully actualized
life have to go through that experience
there are some exceptions but most
people but the other one was connecting
to belief and i think what what changed
me
on this was watching you
do these lectures every night saying the
truth saying i'm just saying what i
believe to be true and trying to take my
thoughts to the to the end and then i'll
explore them further the the next night
but then seeing that translate into real
world change for people the literally
thousands of people who had
unbelievable stories about the terrors
that they had been through that had
turned their lives around and i thought
that that is the higher good that that
is god that it's not that it's
we can do the whole definition game and
all that but but that you
especially at the peak of that thing
we're expressing something that was so
profoundly true
that we all know that maybe we can't
exactly get into the box that we can
just hand to somebody and say this is it
but that that was enough to move me i
think that's i think that's really the
argument you're trying to make that
you'll you'll bring to cambridge and
oxford and to to dawkins and everybody
else yeah well and i would say in your
situation i know you're contemplating
fatherhood and it's probably the right
spirit to inhabit you as a
political
commentator let's say a cultural
commentator so that's a good way to
reconstrue it you know to the degree
that you can be because you're getting
old enough now to that's the right role
you know you're not sort of upward
striving hero youth
it's that you're in that transition
and like benevolent father
that's that's a good one man
and there's no short there's no limit to
the number of people you can bring that
to
and there's no limit to how much good
that'll do in your own life and and in
relationship to your own children
so let me i i know you got to go here so
let me let me just ask you one other
thing just to tie all of this together
um
now looking back at these last couple
years the intellectual pursuits
obviously your health is better
uh at least to some degree you know
you're getting back out on the road
you're gonna start touring and all of
this stuff
um
do you feel that that this is all really
making a dent do you feel like that it's
heavy and it's real and doing something
yes it's more real than anything else i
don't mean what i'm doing specifically
yeah but the sorts of things that we've
been talking about i think the will to
power just folds in in its presence
it's so much more powerful well how can
it not be if it's actually the truth
how can it not be more powerful than
falsehood how can
what isn't there be more powerful than
what is there and why wouldn't we want
to align ourselves with the truth
you know it's really painful in the
short term because there's so much mess
you have to clear up your own and
historical mess even for that matter
but it's better than living in filth
and so
onward and upward and he asked and i'm
optimistic man and i i've seen great
people in your country on both sides of
the political spectrum striving with all
their might to bring things away from
the insane edges
don't lose faith don't lose faith in
your institutions they're great
institutions
they're great institutions fundamentally
and remember we could have
everyone could have enough to eat
everyone could have enough energy
everyone can have an opportunity for
their children all of that
we have all of that in front of us we
have it right now we have it in the next
20 years if we don't
get
suspicious and paranoid and
and power mad and just especially
deceitful
jordan i will
do the best i can actually no i'll try
to do a little better than the best i
can how about that yeah well that would
not be lovely
it was good seeing you my friend good to
see you dave
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes every
interview i've ever done with him and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist both are right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell